what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we have our villains
for the Fantastic Four now a lot of new
information has been coming out recently
about the Fantastic Four we have a few
plot points that have come out recently
plus Marvel Studios has gotten a new
writer for the Fantastic Four and
according to some sources Sue storm and
Reed Richards have already been cast I
covered this in a previous video if you
want to check that out go ahead I'm also
going to be talking about some of it in
this video breaking down the villains
and the plot that we could see in this
new Fantastic Four movie as well as
going over some special presentations
that could be coming up like the Silver
Surfer and Nova so let's go ahead and
dive straight into this new report about
the villains coming in the Fantastic
Four movie and of course if you love The
Fantastic Four and want to stay up to
date on the MCU be sure to subscribe and
if you subscribe and comment on a video
you enter a giveaway for a chance to win
a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items some DC items it's the
user's choice they pick when they win so
this this new report about the Fantastic
Four's villains is coming from Insider
Jeff Snyder who has been dropping a lot
of Scoops recently now this comes with
the news that I briefly mentioned of the
Fantastic Four getting a new writer but
yesterday on the hot Mike podcast he
said this I'm told that Matt shackman is
planning to go very Cosmic with his
Fantastic Four movie lots of the 1960s
elements that the film will feature both
Galactus and the Silver Surfer now this
is honestly what they should do and I
think this is what a lot of fans would
like them to do with a Fantastic Four
movie as long as Galactus isn't a giant
cloud in the sky I think this is what
fans want and I think this is
particularly what Kevin feige wants as
well because you have to remember this
is Kevin feige's the president of Marvel
Studios baby this is his passion project
so he is really involved with all of the
decisions that are being made for the
Fantastic Four now typically Kevin feige
doesn't like to do things things that
have kind of already been done before he
likes to switch things up and yes we've
had the Silver Surfer before and yes
we've kind of had Galactus before but
not really I think you all know what I
mean so having Galactus arrive in the
Fantastic Four movie is different
because I'm pretty sure we're going to
be getting a comic accurate Galactus in
this one plus the Silver Surfer is
probably going to arrive before the
Fantastic Four movie if you've been
following the channel you've heard the
reports that it looks like Marvel
Studios is going to be developing a
Silver Surfer special presentation that
is going to come out before the
Fantastic Four movie this special
presentation is going to be to
specifically introduce the Silver Surfer
in preparation of him arriving in the
Fantastic Four film and it does seem
like this is a plan for Marvel Studios
going forward to introduce some
characters and special presentations
before they appear in the MCU and this
is great because special presentations
allow Marvel to just quickly introduce a
character but not too quickly it's kind
of right in The Sweet Spot you don't
need a six episode Disney plus series to
quickly introduce a character however
you don't want to introduce a character
in 20 minutes so doing a special that's
45 minutes to an hour plus long is
perfect to give us a little bit of an
origin story or whatever story we need
to understand what is about to happen
with the character they did this with
werewolf by night and I think it worked
perfectly it wasn't an origin story but
they introduced the character we know
who the character is along with some
other characters as well and werewolf by
Knight is going to appear again in the
Supernatural side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think that was
executed perfectly and that's what's
apparently going to be happening with
the Silver Surfer you'll get a special
presentation that kind of shows us who
he is what he's about what he's been
doing most likely for Galactus then
we'll meet him again in the Fantastic
Four film now Jeff Snyder goes on in the
podcast to say that they are trying to
take the Fantastic Four film to a whole
nother level and that is why they
actually got a new writer Josh fredman
who was the writer for Avatar 2 the way
of the water so they don't have the old
Riders right now Jeff Kaplan and Ian
Springer but they are still kind of
working off the draft of the movie that
they created here's what Jeff Snyder had
to say Jeff Kaplan and Ian Springer's
draft of the Fantastic Four was fine but
they brought in that new Rider to get it
to the level that Kevin feige and Matt
shackman wanted Marvel is still open to
working with Jeff Kaplan and Ian
Springer again so this is really good
news because that means that Marvel
Studios really does want this movie to
be simply amazing so they looked at the
script that they had before and didn't
really think it was that amazing now
they didn't necessarily think that it
was bad but they wanted it to be on a
whole nother level and apparently this
is going to be going Cosmic the
Fantastic Four are apparently going to
be in space which makes sense now I
don't think we're going to be seeing
them getting their powers in space Kevin
feige already explained that this is not
going to be a true origin story and
reports have told us that they're
actually going to be so far into having
their powers that they're already going
to have kids Sue storm and Reed Richards
and them being in space I think makes a
lot of sense for the plot of this movie
for one thing we heard a report that
they will indeed be parents but they
won't really have their kids much in the
film and if they're going to be in space
well you're obviously not going to be
taking your kids into space in case you
run into some problems like a Herald of
Galactus the Silver Surfer which I'm
assuming happens I'm assuming they're
going to be in space for whatever reason
and then they run into the Silver Surfer
they have a battle and they find out
that Galactus is going to be coming to
devour Earth so they head back to Earth
now I do have a cool little theory about
why the Fantastic Four could be in space
and it does involve Nova some of you
might see where I'm going with this what
if the Fantastic Four are investigating
some things that happened after thanos's
snap and defeat well we know Thanos
decimated xandar so perhaps they make
their way over to zandar to kind of see
the remains of it this could bring Nova
into the picture if the Nova Force has
found its way to the last remaining
Survivor this is Nova and perhaps the
Fantastic Four could run into him on
xandar perhaps he's the only Survivor
and they could offer to take him back to
Earth this is where they could
potentially run into the Silver Surfer
as well the Silver Surfer obviously
wouldn't see zandar as a good Target for
Galactus because nobody would be alive
on it since Thanos decimated it so it
probably wouldn't be enough fuel for
Galactus it wouldn't satisfy his hunger
since there are no living people on it
however the Silver Surfer could see the
Fantastic Four and realize that they
obviously came from somewhere he could
figure out that they came from Earth and
that's when he goes okay cool got a new
planet for Galactus to go to Bower Earth
that's when the Fantastic Four go to
Earth and they figure out a way how to
stop him and this is most likely where
they'll create the ultimate nullifier
although if they go comic accurate this
could lead to a whole other story that
could be really cool in the Fantastic
Four since it is going to be apparently
a cosmic film perhaps the Fantastic Four
don't go back to Earth perhaps they run
into the Watcher like they do in the
comics and he tell tells them that the
only way to actually defeat Galactus and
save Earth is to get the ultimate
nullifier from galactus's Homeworld this
would keep them in space which makes
sense if it is going to be a mostly
Cosmic film in the comics Johnny Storm
goes and he gets it from the base of
Galactus and the ultimate nullifier is
the only known weapon in the entire
universe that was capable of inspiring
fear in Galactus the ultimate nullifier
has been described as the universe's
most devastating weapon and it basically
can just kill any Target that the
wielder chooses and it does this through
the violation of the law of conservation
of mass however there is kind of a catch
your mind has to be super strong to
wield it if your mind isn't powerful
enough to wield it and use it then the
user will die as well so the new
Fantastic Four movie is getting some
changes for a very good purpose to make
the movie fantastic pun intended and I
love that they're bringing in Galactus
and the Silver Surfer it's going to be a
classic Fantastic Four movie however I
don't think that Galactus is going to be
the next big bad now I've actually seen
a lot of debate about this online and I
have to agree with the people that state
Galactus shouldn't be a big bad and the
reason for that is Galactus isn't
necessarily evil I mean he is he goes
and he devours planets and he kills
thousands and millions of people but
that's just who he is he has to satisfy
that hunger that is kind of why he is
Galactus he's not doing this because he
wants to take over the entire universe
he's doing it to satisfy his hunger and
in fact eternity the cosmic entity
eternity even said that Galactus was
necessary for the universe that he
brings the universe balance he's not
personally seeking out Earth he's not
personally going I want to kill the
Fantastic Four I want to kill the
Avengers at least not at first he
doesn't really have a truly villainous
motive to try and destroy all of these
planets he doesn't seek to conquer the
world he doesn't seek to conquer the
universe or the the Multiverse it just
simply does what Galactus does devours
so I don't think the motivating factors
are really there behind Galactus for him
to be a big bad of a new saga I think Dr
Doom or Magneto would be really good big
bads for the next Saga we have coming up
after the Multiverse Saga but I would
like it like it is apparently according
to this report Galactus being a
Fantastic Four villain with his Herald
the Silver Surfer who I am assuming is
kind of going to you know turn against
him and help the Fantastic Four Now
Kevin feige might switch this up a
little bit just to you know try to be
different because that's what he does
and most of the time that does work and
since he's got a new Rider to take the
Fantastic Four to the next level and is
personally overseeing this and making
sure that it is going to be a great
movie I have faith in this movie I don't
think Kevin feige will release this
movie to the public unless he absolutely
loves it so I think we're going to get a
proper Galactus the Silver Surfer
entering the MCU and a really great
Fantastic Four movie but hey let me know
what you think about that in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can enter our giveaway and stay up to
date on the Fantastic Four and the MCU
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf